hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence je t'attends rejoint vite sur
messenger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel courage à perth place une émission
je suis moi je sais qu'on fait une
émission ici dollars par mois mais
rappelez-vous dans la semaine vous voyez
derrière y'a pas de soucis on dévale
ringarde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai plus jamais tu dit ivan c'est
pour ça c'est luca
[Applaudissements]
vous vous êtes du genre à avoir peur
dans la vie ou pas du tout ce qui est
des trucs qui vous font peur or vous
avez peur oui il ya des trucs qui me
font vachement part oui vous avez déjà
eu très très peur
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs je suis
[Rires]
leur reconnaître deux amis joueuse de
badminton hockey
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]